hey it's Jay worthy and I'm right here
with my man bootleg Kev and you can
catch me on the bootleg Kev podcast
episode 300.
300 of these things Jay Worthy's here
what's up Kev very rare Jay worthy
interview in 2023 good to see you man
yeah good to see you too man we always
catch each other out in uh functions yes
sir man you've been working so hard bro
appreciate that you got the tour coming
up I got the tour coming up yeah first
leg of the tour
um excited about that you know what I'm
saying
perform some new material about to come
out so always good you know yeah I feel
like you have a pretty uh insane output
when it comes to just like putting out
bodies of work bro like
for you like what do you what would you
kind of attribute the work ethic to just
you feel it feels like you figured it
out yeah you know
um
I don't know man you know like I I
studied the great you know what I'm
saying and um
you know just
even I'm gonna say it just watching POC
like when he was in the studio he would
tell him like look we're gonna lay all
this [__] down mix and master that [__]
later let's get the verses done on to
the next like I'm always trying to get
to the finish line and um
and it's easy to do when you're like
working on a project with one producer
so for example if I lock in with fraud
we're in there like I just left New York
I was there for a week we did
10 records in two sessions you know what
I'm saying and you guys already got two
albums yeah we got two albums and this
next one is uh me and kamiyah all
produced by um fraud oh yeah man I
wanted to put her on you know like some
different [__] yeah yeah you know
because I I feel like I'm good at you
know I can A and R and curate things
well so it's cool to like you know I'm
like well you know what that hasn't been
done before let's do that you know for
people who don't know man give us your
background obviously you're from L.A
kind of how long you've been making
music where you're from what part of the
city you're from you know from the west
side of Compton
um
um I've been doing this [__] a little
minute you know I kind of came into the
game with yams he was the first one to
kind of discover me
um
you know put out a project in the
SoundCloud ERA with fool's gold and then
my debut EP was with um Alchemist in
2017 that's when I started like
streaming and putting music out so you
know we we got we still knew we still on
the first run you know what I'm saying
I'm gonna run it up some more
but you know
um I've been in the game of you know a
little second I guess
um how did ASAP yams discover you so me
and yams uh we met in Texas you know
what I'm saying and
the way that we met was kind of crazy I
was out [__] around uh at South by
Southwest we was on the same like
showcases or whatnot
um and he just took a liking to me bro
he was like man I [__] with this dude
and you know we had mutual friends like
Dash and stuff and it was a lot of [__]
going on at the South but I think there
was like a rumble somewhere at the fader
Ford or some [__] like that it was that
year but anyways we was wild and out
there we got along and um at the time I
was living with um big face uh games
Brother on uh Brazil in Wilmington and I
brought Dash over there that's um
uh I don't know if you know who Dash is
but he used to rap with them a lot too
that's um Dame Dash nephew and I put him
on a joint and we shot a video and yams
liked it and you know what I'm saying
and this time I was kind of figuring out
my sound I was like you know I just
wanted to rap over oldies and you know
Loop [__] up
um
yeah you know so he kind of gave me the
direction like you know he get he put
the confidence in me because before I
was just rapping in the hood right with
the homies and the only like you know
success I had seen at the time you know
was like game or uh you know uh I used
to run around with sugar and you know
just soak up game from him but
this was some new [__] you know what I'm
saying and I I like the way the
direction like I like the way the music
was going and like this was around like
everybody was hanging out at Fairfax and
I'm just you know what I'm saying Street
Wear culture skateboard and all that
type of [__] and I was like oh this [__]
is cool and it can get me out of the
hood so
um you know I started [__] around and
moving in those circles a little bit
okay what year were you running around
with Suge Knight damn shook probably
like young like
2008 nine yeah maybe 2007 even yeah yeah
yeah shook would give me a lot of game
man um you know and bring bring us
around and stuff and um
but you know I I seen the game change
and and you know I had to take a
different approach and um
you know you got to move with the times
you know what I'm saying how did you
guys initially connect who me and should
yeah well just you know just Compton
[__] you know what I'm saying so
um you know some of the big homies
um you know was [__] with him and you
know brought me around him and he took a
liking to me and are you making music at
this time uh I was but I was like you
know I'd kind of like I'd gotten you
know more caught up in Street [__] I'm
not gonna lie and like music was just
like second secondary I mean yeah it was
like a hobby but
I um you know I definitely still did it
but it wasn't like you know what I'm
saying I was I didn't know really what
direction to go in yet you know what I'm
saying I didn't really have my sound
like before I started doing this stuff
is learning drugs
I had put out one tape with mustard and
um
I would just take different songs from
different Studios and I'm like mustard
was the homie so he hosted it yeah
before he was making beats yeah this is
he was making BT it just did Rack City
okay so like and then Nemo it hit me
that's how I got in the Empire system
because I remember I just threw the tape
out there this is still like like
physicals and like
um a couple of my boys that were uh from
like the jungles
um they were like instead of just
putting the tapes
um
and swap meets and liquor stores around
the hood you should go up to Fairfax and
put it in the hundreds and supreme and
diamonds yeah yeah yeah so that kind of
like brought me up there and then
um you know people on that side of town
started hearing my [__] so I was like
you know I had the right intentions to
do it but I wasn't like it wasn't until
like you know I got with Sean and
started like you know really figuring
out my sound and what I wanted to do and
then um you know with the help of yeah
it was just kind of
showing me the ropes a little bit you
know yams did a lot he put me with Vice
and then that led into me producing that
um documentary with Kendrick or about
Kendrick and my homies called noisy
bompton and that then also had Vice vers
doing all of my videos then I had Fool's
Gold you know what I'm saying so that
was like kind of the push that pushed me
into like
all right I'm gonna take music serious
all the way you know what I'm saying
yeah I feel like you've kind of like
done a really good job of like
I guess being in the right circles
having the right people co-sign you yeah
yeah and I think that's really important
too you know like uh the whole [__] went
out I was like Monumental for me to be
able to have like him do my first solo
you know EP and then through there
that's how like you know me and Gunn and
Conway met you know what I'm saying like
the first tour I ever went on was uh it
was just me and Conway uh gun and Benny
it was just us four
yeah what's the side track what's up
with the uh Griselda debut so you know
it's guns are busy dude I'm a busy dude
we want to make sure that it's done
right we want to be in the lab at the
same time you know uh
I have you know
producers that I work closely with he
has the producers that he works closely
with and
we're just gonna come put it together
you know it's got to be a pot of Gumbo
but you guys got to kind of be actively
working on it for sure because like you
know you need to be in there with
conductor and all that conductor you
know what I'm saying and Derringer well
me and Derringer got an EP done but we
we keep like
changing it up but um
yeah and monk you know what I'm saying
but the thing is with that it's like
it's just timing man everybody's busy
and moving around but it's gonna come I
want my debut solo to come out on
Griselda so
it's crazy you say that and you have so
much music yeah because I won't even be
able to put out my solo album this year
I got me and rock Marcy album The me
Kamai and Harry Fraud and then I got a
funk album with um with uh Dame Funk and
um and then I got another album with
cocaine the singer and those are Kane
yeah me and cocaine got like a whole
like kind of like a funk group we doing
called Billy Ocean where
um I've taken some of the cats that
produced for like selection like I am
nobody yeah and then um Jake won in
traffic leaving Cali you know what I'm
saying and then uh me and Sean and you
know me and Coca got some cold [__] so
it's a lot of it's tough because you
know like us in the Indie like I don't
like saying underground you know what
I'm saying I like to remove that word
but I said underground is kind of not a
thing anymore no this could be a thing
but I feel like
there's so much there's just some genres
of this [__] there's the independent I
mean yeah I feel like the underground
[__] is out the door I feel like it
because it's like what you call what
Larry and Alchemists are doing
underground I wouldn't how is it that's
a major rollout you know what I'm saying
like and it's being pushed um because
back in the day you would think of like
guys like Dilated Peoples it's
underground yes but it wouldn't even
really be underground because they were
on Capitol or like yeah yeah yeah like
even like the raucous record [__] or but
the real underground [__] out of La was
the project blows project blow free
stuff yeah bus driver all those and and
I got a lot of history with those cats
when I was like 13 you know uh I was
running around like with um with uh with
cve and and and La cool rifle man and
soaking up game that type of music
actually opened my whole [__] up because
I really only like was listening to
gangster rap and like East Coast [__] at
the time and then I was like oh it's
some [__] coming out of L.A that's like
different you know what I mean so uh how
old are you
oh we gonna do that well I'm trying to
figure out because yeah I'm an 80s baby
you know what I'm saying I'm born in 87
but I was my best friend's brothers and
Dilated Peoples oh yeah so when I was
like who's your best friend's brother
Rocca oh [__] yeah Evans my boy yeah
that was my boy too yeah that's right
I've known evidence I was 13. really
yeah damn so I like
I remember seeing them
uh on the platform tour and then when
they dropped expansion team we came out
here when I was like 14 and went to the
record release party and [__] fat
beats and they had to show a Jurassic
five at some [__] and then then when
they had the marathon drop they were
they opened up for Kanye a House of
Blues yeah so I was around all that [__]
bro yeah yeah yeah that [__] was dope
man that whole like um like that's why
even like while we talking about this
like I like to do [__] and bring like
for me I like to work with people that I
grew up on like so I'm like I did a song
with Tash and we just put out a video
shout out to the licks man shout outs to
the licks rap life that's one of my
favorite albums man that was the [__]
that him and him and uh rake one had
that video that was the [__] but you
know like for me like
you know Tad Tash I invited Tash and he
Swift to my house and then I was like
let's shoot this video I bought like a
whole in Compton I bought this whole
[__] like Warehouse full of like
vintage denims and like I got dead stock
for days like FUBU averex Pelle Pelle
you got traffic denim jackets denim
shirts everything we about to launch um
about to launch a store with um
this uh reworks company called Frankie
Collective so that's going to be coming
in the spring you know what I'm saying
paper Rex is when I was like 15 we'd get
them for Burlington but they'd be like
[__] 4X yeah they'd be 4X yeah you
see they're coming back though
they all like relaunching their [__] and
like you know I always been into
um fashion like people don't know this
but I'm like you know the you know kind
of the
I don't know what my title is I would
say but you know maybe the head of
marketing over at Pro Club you know what
I mean I took that and saw an
opportunity to be like this is a dope
ass this is a staple it's a staple we
grew up on it in the hood everybody grew
up on it in LA and like I wanted to see
it just you know still keep its roots in
the swap meets and liquor stores but
start doing collaborations so when I
came on board we did the collaboration
with YG at complexcon started doing the
um three packs with FTP we did the
pop-up for Shoreline at um
uh didn't cookies just do a Pro Club
yeah well we did that yep and and then
we had you know burner was rocking that
Pro Club on the Forbes which was tight
you know what I'm saying so you know uh
the fashion [__] is always I feel like
being a part of um you know music every
every rapper had when they was popping
every rapper had a brand if it was Nas
it was Esko of course I I always thought
Johnny Blaze was Method Man because he's
Johnny Blaze yeah yeah Johnny Blazers
was I just remember seeing the [__] in
the source I never got any of it yeah
yeah so they had a gang of that [__] so
I just grabbed all that [__] so we'll
see what it do with that I'm also gonna
launch my own line this year but you
know uh back to the Tash story uh I was
like yo let's shoot a commercial for my
uh for my uh all the Vintage pieces and
jump jump on this old [__] and we shot a
video but I just like to work with cats
that you know I grew up listening to so
when I was able to meet Cube and you
know erupt and and Bun and all these
cats it's like a blessing to me man
because you know that's what inspired me
um to do what I do so for me it's like
the 13 year old me is like living your
dreams I'm living my dream yeah right
you know it's bootleg cab here gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
good friends at King Palm now listen
guys all I do is smoke out of King Palm
if you see me smoking it's out of King
Palm all right and I'm gonna shout them
out because it's all natural
no tobacco it's a tobacco-free uh
product also no additives no need to
split it open no need to lick it comes
ready to go all you have to do
is put your uh your tree your flower of
choice right into here and you're good
to go now the best thing about King Palm
they have these turbine enough infused
wraps right here they're flavored uh
this is my favorite I do love watermelon
all right burst of watermelon flavor
again no tobacco no additives all
natural all you got to do is pack it and
you aren't ready to go now this is
what's dope about King Palm if you go to
the website right now you know they're
the new sponsor I've been using them
forever so I had to hit them up like hey
guys I'm tired of smoking your guys's
[__] I'd love some support on the
podcast of course all right so go to
kingpom.com right now use the promo code
bootleg Kev and You're Gonna Save 50 off
um you can get whatever you need you can
order it online because these are
tobacco free no nicotine baby all right
so you can get it right to your house
half off kingpom.com keyword bootleg
heavy you can also hit your local
7-Eleven you could also hit your local
smoke shop one of the best selling
brands in America at the smoke shop so
many different products rollable wraps
hemp cones all the smoking accessories
one would ever need the smoothest smoke
the easiest to use
what are you [__] doing if you're
smoking and you're smoking at anything
but this you're [__] crazy all right
go check them out online socials one
more time kingpom.com promo code bootleg
save half off taking you on that natural
path King pong baby hey also shout out
to the homies at Blue chew man don't
forget if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction if your penis is not
functioning correctly
it's a little flaccid you're trying to
get it a little hard a lot of hard
rather Bluetooth is where it's at a lot
of people ask me you always talk about
Bluetooth does it work yes it works all
right uh listen it has the same active
ingredient as Viagra and as Cialis but
it's in a chewable form all right it is
sent right to your door uh in a discrete
package it's a great thing man go to
bluetooth.com right now you use that
promo code bootleg right now you're
gonna get a month supply for free of
Bluetooth why not have some better sex
okay seriously uh there's so many other
ways you can get down too because they
just dropped the Bluetooth mint flavor
which is the same active ingredient as
Levitra just so many things we can do
here uh and look when you go to
bluetooth.com and you sign up with that
promo code bootleg they're gonna
literally send it straight to your crib
for free five dollars in shipping you
get a month supply for free now how does
it work one you don't need to go to any
doctor's appointments it's all handled
online with an online pharmacist you
don't have to worry about going and
sitting in a waiting room to go discuss
your dick with some strange dude or
chick hmm maybe you're into that I don't
know with that being said it's an
awkward situation all right if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction all
you need to do is go to bluetooth.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you'll get one month supply for free
zero dollars right to your door your
wife will even never know it even
happened you know what I'm saying maybe
you've been a little embarrassed you're
tired of piping down that same old bra
that you've been sleeping with for the
last 35 years put a little pep in your
step man take a Bluetooth use that promo
code bootleg bluetooth.com and try it
for free also got a shout out to my
bookie man Final Four Is On The Way NBA
playoffs are here well almost here we
got like a few games left right so much
going on you got the Masters coming up
man so many ways to win money
join us in my bookie I've been using my
bookie for about a decade now it's where
I put all my bets in uh there's so many
ways to win money with my bookie if you
go to my bookie right now you sign up
mybookie.ag promo code bootleg and you
will get
double deposit bonus action that means
your very first deposit up to a thousand
dollars make that deposit with that
promo code bootleg when you sign up for
that new account and they're gonna give
you uh uh another thousand dollars
they're gonna double your first deposit
so you might put 200 in you might put
500 in they will give you another 200
another 500 to gamble with all right so
much to do with my bookie obviously we
love betting on sports literally one of
my biggest passions in life is gambling
away my money and winning money on
mybookie.ag now I got a few Futures
going on right now I got Joelle embed
doing the MVP I got the Phoenix Suns to
win the West I got the Bucks to win the
East NCAA action I'm taking UConn all
the way what are y'all doing go to my
bookie right now they got the props you
can do the player props you can do the
over unders you can do whatever you need
plus live Blackjack live roulette I have
so much fun on my bookie you really
don't ever need to leave your house
shout out to my booking mybookie.ag sign
up right now with the promo code bootleg
and get that first deposit bonus
what are we talking about who else is
going to double your first deposit
ladies and gentlemen mybookie.ag promo
code bootleg sign up and let's win some
money now let's get back to the
interview you uh you you mentioned
living with big face and I just remember
big face 100 being like games brother
and then they had this falling out and
this was like early like uh
I wouldn't even say YouTube maybe but it
was like DVD [__] but I just remember
that there was like a big division
between those two obviously
game uh being a Compton Legend his
brother being a Compton Legend yeah uh
what was your guys's relationship like
well I didn't really know again I've met
game like maybe you know a couple times
when he was like you know as he was
blowing up and stuff but my relationship
was more with face you know what I'm
saying um through a couple of the big
homies from my hood and at the time I
didn't have nowhere to uh you know I
didn't have nowhere to stay so you had a
piece to stay with him yeah he opened
this house to me and that ended up
turning into a long time so I was there
like you know what I mean and then that
those days that's when I met Freeway
Rick and I was selling Indian hair and
then he was selling hair and we was
trapping trapping the hair trapping the
hair all over all over Compton South
Central everywhere Watts we was really
making some good money off of here until
the uh until that game got saturated you
know what I'm saying so that shit's
crazy man Rick to go get free clothes on
Fairfax we would go get all the
um promo stuff and then like you know I
would wear most of that [__] but Rick
would go and flip that [__] shout out to
freeway Rickman yeah that's my dog man
me and Rick got a lot of history man
we've been um we've been broke together
and we got rich together so
um you have collab projects with some of
the most legendary producers you got an
album with mugs you got a I'm an
alchemist you got a couple albums with
hairy fraud you got rock Marciano the
collab album coming out yeah for you
what is like
give me kind of like the breakdown on
like the creative process on working
with each one of these guys because I'm
sure it everyone's different yeah
producers creative processes the maybe
you know whether it's recording whatever
what's what's the difference between
everybody everybody
I mean for the most part bro like we all
like friends so you know
um
I like I really like getting in there
with fraud because Fraud's like a good
coach he'll be like nah say it like this
or not you need to retake that again
um someone recently told me he'd be in
the Hamptons yep that's where we
recorded that second album so we went
out to the Hamptons that [__] was dope
and you know like fraud surf so he'll
like wake up go surfing and then we'll
go you know yeah yeah yeah exactly so um
uh yeah I like everybody's different you
know what I'm saying but um the main
thing is we're all friends so it's like
I like to make music with people that I
know you know I like to have personal
relationships and um I think that makes
the music better you know what I'm
saying when you really like family like
that but um I didn't say that it felt
like the Larry June album caught a lot
of like lists last year I had I think
that's my like yeah best album last year
but do you feel like that album kind of
brought a lot more eyes to you and your
movement and what you got going on
probably so you know I don't know
because like yeah I mean I'm not one to
like I'm I'm a very private person I
don't really like being in the media too
much
um so that one probably you know Larry's
on fire right now there's a great bro
great [__] album thank you I
appreciate that you know that's that's
Sean you know from our group London
drugs and we uh
we put that together but you know me and
Larry is like real life Brothers you
know what I'm saying that's like my best
friend so it was just you know we we'd
been sitting some of those songs are
like six years old crazy on there yeah
one of the songs the song with Jim Jones
I actually did that verse in 2013 and
put it out now you know what I'm saying
but that's why nine years later yeah Ten
Years Later yeah you know and I just
feel like well it came out last oh yeah
it came out last year yeah so I just
feel like you know if it's Timeless it's
Timeless like I don't really feel like
um you know what I still listen to death
certificate you know I still listen to
dog food you know like it came out
yesterday so
they do the same with my [__] you feel
me I ain't trying to put a um
a year stamp on my [__] like that yeah
for you
I don't feel like I when I I remember
buying like the jizz and mugs album I
remember that it was a great album
um but I feel like mugs doesn't do as
much like full collab projects with
people so I feel like the fact you got
an album with mugs is insane oh yeah
that's a big deal man that's not so
assassin [__] like that shit's a big
deal like where did that relationship
stem from and like well I think mugs
probably got hip to me from Al you know
what I'm saying
um
and just seeing my [__] and you know we
was mutual friends through a lot of
people and one day he was like yeah pull
up to the studio let's make some [__]
and we just started it and you know I
already had in my mind when I go started
something with a producer especially
like a legendary producer like that I'm
trying to get the album done bro like
and you've done a good job of doing that
hey I'm trying to get the album done you
know what I'm saying so
um
yeah uh
that was a great experience you know
that's a legend you know I my first CD I
think I ever bought as a kid
was the Predator you know what I'm
saying so you know he had a lot of
production on there
and you know yeah I came up on Cyprus
and all that [__] so for me it's like
you're in mugs the studio and you're
looking at the plaques and you're like
looking basically looking at an Old
Source magazine and then you like this
is dope you know what I mean so that
[__] was fire how how high is Ice Cube
on your like goats list
that's like the guy you know for sure to
me um as far
is
you know those give me give me your like
top five
your personal favorite I I can't really
do a top five man that [__] is really
hard for me to do man but cube is
definitely in there you know what I'm
saying most definitely
um Cube
Nas is in there too you know
um
I don't know I'm gonna just leave those
two on there those are two good ones
yeah yeah those two for sure because
Illmatic and death certificate those was
like okay yeah
would you consider death certificate his
best album to me yeah I think so to me I
feel like in in I feel like I feel like
it should I feel like it's kind of the
consensus yeah yeah I feel like
America's Most Wanted got the five mics
right yeah yeah because America's Most
Wanted is like but I was a little like
just the style of production for me was
like a little still I was bought I love
it I go back to it now and I really got
into it but when I was like younger I
liked like you know steady mobbing and
and [__] like that I was like oh and
then like you know I I'm I still love
lethal injection for sure he's like
crazy so I just had Mac 10 on it I was
like dude
I've seen that [__] you know hey I was
like oh [__] yeah yeah that's that's
dope what is your because I always get
into arguments I have like two or three
albums that are always rotating as my
greatest album of all time it's Illmatic
or it's doggy style usually one or two
um what's your what's your favorite I'm
I'm gonna give the old head answer
though like for me still to this day and
even though I'm from the west coast and
all that to me top to bottom nomadic
yeah yeah it is
yeah yeah it's Illmatic I'm gonna I'm
gonna be honest that that one changed
the game I remember going to the record
store and the dude was in there it was
me and my relative and he was like nah
it was like not you know nine or ten or
something like that and he's like this
is that [__] you know what I'm saying it
was like oh and
never never got old to me I still you
know have you met nausea nah that's
somebody I haven't met I haven't met I
haven't met Nas I haven't met Jay but I
I didn't you know everybody out here you
know I haven't met but uh
you know and we're speaking of the East
Coast like Dipset you know like that was
my [__] so for me and Jim and me and Jim
got a personal relationship because you
know Jim was [__] with the homies
early on certified gangsters he was he
was in that wasn't he yeah yeah he was
in the hood early [__] with foe Ben
rest in peace [__] with hot dog and
and um wacko I just I just randomly saw
that video again like two weeks ago I
don't know popped up on my YouTube and I
was like damn Booyah tribe in there this
[__] was really in concert and
that wasn't like there wasn't people
like didn't come to the hood like that
then in like and Jim was banging so when
Jim came out west like he was tipping
through hoods and like tapping in like
you know what I'm saying and you know
really like similar like I got to give
it up to Waka Flocka too because like
that was around the days when we would
be around sugar like Walker really came
out here and tapped in and when he made
flockavelli he went grab the homies and
put YG hoodie on Brick Squad put ice B
put Joe Moses winning shot hard in the
pain in the jungles you know what I'm
saying I was dope you know what I mean
it's kind of like it's wild to really
think that like
um a lot of the like you know because
back in the 90s you know
the Crips had more of the right right
they were the more popular like if you
think about like yeah dog man that's all
really got to know the biggest rapper in
the world is Snoop and the homies it's
like to be honest like Jim Jones and
like Lil Wayne kind of brought
I feel like he kind of attention for
sure to it yeah even though it wasn't
from L.A yeah yeah but it you know what
I mean it was like game Wayne yeah game
for sure too yeah but yeah you know
Wayne and Jim like you know they was It
was a they was putting on man but yeah
shout outs to gym that's the big bro you
know that when I'm in New York I lived
in New York for like two years I lived
in Harlem so they got that's like New
York really like my second home they
they love me out there I just did a show
with rock sold it out in uh Brooklyn and
like I was like damn that was really
like giving it up Lord Jamar came up to
me and he was like I don't know you I
never done nothing but I watched your
setting that [__] was dope you know what
I'm saying I was like
I'm the type of flowers I need these are
the ones you want they add them the ones
I want you feel me hey we gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family at Odd Socks baby that's
right shout out to Odd Socks little
Godfather sock right there craziest
licenses in the game the most
comfortable socks period And if you go
to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg you're gonna get
20 off at checkout now they also got the
underwear going on these are some Street
Fighter draws let's pop these boys open
check them out
oh yeah oh yeah a little Chun Lee versus
Blanco
what
amazing
do you like YooHoo so much that you'd
wear Yoo-hoo on your feet
there's people wandering around out here
with goddamn hot Cheeto jumpsuits right
now so of course you would shout out to
you who they got crazy licenses we
already mentioned Street Fighter
Coca-Cola Pepsi yes they got the they
got the both there they got Pepsi and
Coca-Cola uh they also got Scarface
Breaking Bad WWE so many dope licenses
plus their Odd Socks Basics line which
are these just kind of the normal socks
in my opinion are the most comfortable
socks I've ever put on my feet
I promise you you gotta go to
autotoxofficial.com right now and use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off your
entire order all right so go do that
oddsoxofficial.com also want to give a
shout out to our family at hardean
that's right Harding the craziest
dispensary you've ever walked into in
your life Hardy in Las Vegas you got to
pull up follow them on Instagram Harding
underscore Las Vegas you see the Hat you
see the logo shout out to the family at
hardean if you're in Vegas you got to
stop off you got to go pick you up some
weed it is legal in Vegas tell them I
sent you they're gonna take care of you
all right uh make sure you follow them
Harding underscore Las Vegas the largest
selection of previous cannabis I've ever
seen in my life the best smelling place
I've ever walked into in my life they
have a signature scent that's [__]
insane so shout out to hardine go follow
him Hardy underscore Las Vegas check out
more info about them at
jardinlasvegas.com let's get back to the
interview so the rock Marciano album you
were just telling me some of the
features off the air you got some crazy
features man big dogs man big dogs so
you know what I'm saying uh yeah Legends
you know what I'm saying a rock hit me
uh last night and he was like yo he's
like this [__] feel like we we making
The Chronic I said oh damn I said if you
feel like that then I know we got some
[__] but um man it's been a pleasure to
work with Rock and it's been um cool to
Showcase him because everybody know he
the hardest at rapping no he can rap his
ass on but he's also an amazing producer
that part you know so what he's doing
for me is he's producing the album he's
rapping on it too but not you know maybe
just one joint you know what I'm saying
so I want to leave some of the some of
the uh features yeah well you told me a
lot of them and they're pretty it's
pretty crazy yeah but I'll tell you this
though we got um we got bun on there
yeah I'm going out to um I got a show in
Austin April 4th and then I shoot out to
uh Houston to go to the video yeah yeah
uh for you because it is kind of crazy
to think like I don't think there's been
another artist
that has really like obviously shout out
to Freddie Freddy's and stuff with Mad
Lib and and ow I feel like you've done
such a good job though if you go all the
way back because the London Drug [__] is
is you want a producer right it's me and
the producer right and so you've been
doing that consistently for so long it's
kind of like your business model at this
point it is and I'm not I'm not gonna
say that I kicked it off or nothing
because you know of course
um I mean Wu-Tang look man they what
that was all Rizza gang star mob deep
mob you know what I'm saying well I mean
I mean not all of my deep space it was
like it was like having a gang star but
Gang Starr was all Prodigy I mean all
Premiere and Premiere actually gave me a
shout out recently which that meant a
lot to me you know what I'm saying on
the mug [__] so also not all the Wu-Tang
[__] was risen right the first time who
was the first time I think I think 32
Chambers was but we'll take forever was
mathematics yeah yeah yeah right right
so but yeah I mean I've done that
um
I mean I like to create I like to create
a sound you know what I'm saying I feel
like Fantasy Island
with Al that had a sound active with
Sean that had a sound the cardo the G
worthy project that had a sound like you
you know it it's cool to do that but I
think what will be interesting is when I
really put out my first debut solo and
it's different producers Zelda yeah and
it's different producers because like
you're bringing all the worlds together
man I got so many EPS that I started and
didn't finish like me and Jake one got
some [__] oh I loved white van music man
I even got some [__] with that
Thundercat produced for me that I ain't
even like do you know what I'm saying
yeah like I'm trying to like show people
some other [__] when I drop my solo
album like here this is Jay Worthy's uh
yeah this is his studio album is that
what they've used to call it this studio
album right yeah yeah this is my label
album right now we still just warming up
and getting the fun [__] done would you
and uh Perico do another G worthy I
would love to yes he's his output since
he got a rotation it's been crazy he's
he's bro he always put the Energizer uh
charge in my back because when he'll be
like man what you doing man let's drop
drop like he his model is crazy and he's
he's turning up right now he's turning
up his tour is looking amazing
um he's on like yeah he's on double time
right now I gotta catch up I gotta
definitely do a uh we need to we need to
do G worthy too
um you know it's just cardo's busy he's
busy I'm busy and the way G works is a
lot different than me like I've me and
Larry work very similar like send me the
[__] and I'll get it done and you know
what I mean I'll just be in there with
Sean or my engineer and I knock it out
but the way G worthy was made it was
made in one day and we had everybody in
the studio a live cook up it was a live
cook up and and there's something to be
said about that because if you look at
the classics like chronic and doggy
style
you know they was at Dre house and they
was knocking [__] out all together as a
unit and you know music comes out fun
like that so I gotta you know I think we
gotta get in the all together in one
room for that to happen again but
it'll happen one day would you and uh
with all the success and the love you
got for the uh Alma later you guys
talking about doing this oh yeah that's
forever that's for life too man two peas
in a pot is like a group you know what
I'm saying like and if you see like you
know they just dropped the track listen
for him and Al's project I'm on that you
know he was just on my last project with
Harry we we keep uh we keep it we keep
each other
um going you know what I'm saying we we
it's the brand at this point you know
what I'm saying so the tours uh come in
make sure you go get tickets yeah go get
those tickets Rock Marcy album on the
way Rock Marcy album on the
[__] way kamiyah collab
projects with hairy Frost so much this
year and Dame Funk if y'all not hip to
that
go get hip to that go get hip to that
man well listen I appreciate you pulling
up we had to finally make it happen man
thank you it's been an honor yes sir my
guy Jay worthy boom